I did a lot of heavy benching in my
career I'd never built my pecs as well
as when I trained with flex wheeler
using incline dumbbell presses they
allow more depth and they allow
independent rotation of the shoulders so
I get less potential shoulder injury
what are the cues that you're thinking
of or that you're telling your clients
when you're looking at the incline
dumbbell press 45° angle of the elbow
this is the one exercise so far that
every single person has had in and no
one's had flat bench dumbbell press 45°
angle on the arms deep elbow try and
wrap that Peck around around the rib
cage as best you can I don't want to be
out here it's going to hit the shoulder
I want to be in here so it's the PEC and
I want to use that rib cage so in order
to do that I'm going to actually lift my
sternum up and expand the rib cage and
then the deeper I can get my elbow use
that because you want to have as much
lengthening of the chest muscle or any
muscle that you train as possible it's
going to grow better in the lengthened
position full range of motion oh I just
love that incline dumbbell so much